حرب المياه بين ايران وافغانستان الطرفان
يعجزان عن الوصول لارضيه للتفاهم خلاف حاد
طفى على السطح مجددا بين ظهرا وطالبان حول
طريقه توزيع مياه نهر هلمان اطول نهر في
افغانستان وقبل الخوض في التفاصيل دعونا
نتعرف على فصول هذا الخلاف يتمحور الخلاف
الايراني الافغاني بشان الماء اساسا حول
نهرها المند الذي ينبع من جبال هندوك شمال
شرقي افغانستان او هندو كوش بالاحرى وتصب
مياه النهر نهر هلمان في بحيره هامون داخل
الاراضي الايرانيه بعد قطع ما يزيد على
1300 كيلومتر ويعد هذا النهر اهم مورد
للمياه بالنسبه للبلدين افغانستان وايران
ولتنظيم التوزيع العادي لمياه نهر هلمنت
وقعت ايران وافغانستان اتفاقيه قديمه تعود
الى عام
1973 وبموجب الاتفاقيه تمنح افغانستان
لايران 26 متر مكعبا من المياه في الثانيه
الواحده وعلى هذا الاساس يتدفق الى ايران
سنويا 820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
القادمه من افغانستان ولكن هذه الاتفاقيه
لم تحل الخلاف بين الجانبين حيث ظلت
الازمه المائيه طاغيه على العلاقات
الايرانيه الافغانيه فرغم ان افغانستان
تحوز على 57 مليار متر مكعب من متوسط
المياه الانهار السنوي الا انها لا تستهلك
اقل من 30% من هذه الكميه ويذهب المتبقي
الى دول الجوار
لهذا السبب بادرت كابول منذ سنوات الى
تبني سياسه تشييد السدود على انهار عده
تصل روافدها الى ايران وهي السياسه التي
حافظت عليها طالبان خطوه اعادت اثاره
حفيظه طهران التي تعتبر ان هذه السدود
تحول دون وصول المياه بكميات كافيه الى
اراضيها وقالت طهران انها خسرت العام
الماضي اربعه ملايين متر مكعب من المياه
القديمه من افغانستان غير ان طالبان عزت
سبب تراجع تدفق المياه لايران الى قله
هطول الامطار والجفاف تبرير ترد عليه
طهران بالقول ان لديها صورا جويه تظهر
وفره المصادر المائيه في افغانستان
وفي خضم هذه الخلافات بين الجانبين تحدث
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبدالله
يان عن مطالبه ايران بحصتها المائيه من
نهرها المند وادلى عبد الله هيان بتصريح
مثير على خلفيه هذه الازمه بالقول ان
بلاده لا تعترف بحكومه افغانستان الحاليه
داعيا الى تشكيل حكومه شامله في هذا البلد
وشدد عبد الله يهان على ضروره اتباع
المسار القانوني بخصوص الازمه
وفي اخر تطورات القضيه تطالب ايران
بالسماح لها بافاد مختصين لها لزياره سدود
افغانستان طلب قبل بالرفض من قبل طالبان
حيث قال المتحدث باسم الحركه ذبيح الله
مجاهد ان زياره الايرانيين للسدود
افغانستان لم تتم الاشاره اليها في
الاتفاق الموقعي عام 73 في المقابل بلغ
تصعيد طهران حد التهديد بطرد بطرد
اللاجئين الافغان من ايران واغلاق السفاره
الافغانيه وقطع طرق البضائع الى افغانستان
وهو ما نقله رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد
باقر قليباث
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات